so what I'd like to do first is look at
Force 452
this is a bill which we're dealing with
and we have to get out of committee this
next week and it deals with the entire
building Aid Grant application process
and there are several components within
I just like to walk through really
quickly with you that we are looking at
significant things which give the
rationale for why we are doing this bill
today
I think everybody understands that
probably the most important thing we
have to do is the timeline for Grants is
the current process is a timeline that
just so pinched and by the way for
everybody here representative Hill is
Chairman of the school building
authority which has a a component or
responsibility tied directly with
of this building application process
that we have established right now
so I'd like to walk through that and and
uh highlight some of the primary things
which we have you you also have a sheet
did you all get this sheet right here
this is sheet that has comments on the
side
that's the bill but we also have an
amendment to the bill but I want to look
at this one right here it has some of
the amend mending language within but
just hitting on some of the key
components that we may want to be
discussing on the first page that one
has HP 452 as introduced and the word
introduced has been scratched out and
amended 3 2 23. on the bottom of that
page on lines 28 going on down there's
an area which
um
has been a
possible issue of contention that we pay
when a School receives this money they
get 80 percent up front
and 20 20 upon completion of the project
and that is that decisions made by Amy
when they complete that project then
then uh that's uh when they will receive
that other 20 there are those out there
saying that perhaps we ought not be
funding 80 up front maybe we should be
sprinkling that over the period lifetime
of the bond enabling more school
districts to receive building Aid on the
businessman
yeah and it's been proposed to by a
number of folks when we've had the
hearings here that's coming from a lot
of directions the reason why this 80 up
front was put there
there are several reasons one of which
it results in the local school district
not having to pay the interest on that
bond for that period of time they're
going to get 80 up front is that correct
Amy
it
probably because it was in the calendar
so then I will push the button that's
correct representative
thank you okay so I wanted to highlight
that one right there and there is a
comment there which uh reference it
uh as you go down through on page two
you can see that there's some comments
and same eligibility criteria conditions
for the the charter school as Lea we we
have inline online three at the top
there on page two the amount of the
grant to any Charter Public School
established in accordance with the rsab
blah blah blah shall be 30 percent of
the eligible cost of construction
there's been some issues associated with
this uh Amy in terms we have it here but
we don't have it elsewhere in statute is
that correct that's correct charter
schools are essentially prohibited in a
correct why not correct
yeah
this this is good right so this goes
through this committee next week
so that's why we're doing this now so
building it allows Charter Schools it
has a um it has a rate let me just say
building it has a 30 flat rate for
Charter Schools however somewhere else
in the law in the charter school law
says that um they can't apply to for
building Aid which doesn't that's not
verbatim but essentially prohibits them
from seeking building Aid
okay on line five on that same page
funds received from charitable trust
bequests gifts insurance policies
federal grants
or grants from other state programs
shall be subtracted from the total
project costs when Computing grants
under this paragraph that's been in law
a long time but that's also a
we wanted to speak to that from my own
personal experience I would like to do
that at your you know at your discretion
before you leave the topic well we're
going to be leaving that topic real
shortly here so so watching her while
you drove down from Coburg or Pittsburgh
so
let's give you the opportunity you are
I'm not busy tomorrow
yeah oh I know I've uh
I don't mind making the trip truly but
thank you very much
may I begin yes go ahead oh thank you so
as I think you all know my name is
Deborah Taylor and I'm the
superintendent of schools for sau7 which
includes Clarksville Cobra Colombia
Pittsburgh and Stewartstown school
districts and I've searched for 15 years
as a superintendent three in my current
position
so I'm here today to implore you to make
very necessary changes to proposed HB
452 changes that with a stroke of your
pen will change the lives of the
students in the Colebrook school
district and our surrounding communities
let me briefly tell our story
last fall the Colebrook School District
was notified we were ranked number two
for eligibility for building Aid
we presented uh a 16.5 million dollar
project and were approved for 60 percent
of the State Building Aid up to 9.9
million dollars
estimated
and dependent upon legislative
Appropriations
our school board and District building
Committee in conjunction with their
architectural firm created a modest
design including High School classrooms
and Labs which integrated our newly
approved North Point CTE Center on the
same campus as a elementary school
our committee and parent support group
initiated a Community Information
campaign colebrook's a small town and
our net assessment assess valuation is
just over 193 million
the school includes one Pre-K 12 school
with 320 students housed in an
elementary school as well as tuition
students from six towns in the
surrounding area
our high school students transitioned to
the elementary school when the academy
closed in 2019 because it was unsafe and
provided many difficulties for that were
much too costly to repair the original
um we also had a tech building behind
that building which we're currently
leasing because the old school has been
sold and that leases up in three years
so our project includes building an
addition as I mentioned of 28 300 square
feet and a renovation of 7 700 square
feet including conversion of existing
well at this point we were looking at
existing administrative spaces but we've
recently changed subsequently excuse me
had changed that to include a separate
building which about for the same cost
which would be more efficient including
a health science lab computer technology
Center automotive technology bays and a
new high school gym
the site development costs were also
included including utility work parking
area and Landscaping as well as
contingency funds
so now I'm going to quote do a quote for
you I hope you don't mind I enjoy poetry
and literature and this one really
seemed to fit for me today so I'm sure
you're all familiar with this is very
famous from Charles Dickens The Tale of
Two Cities and expresses our
circumstances well
so with that background it was the best
of times it was the worst of times it
was the age of wisdom it was the age of
foolishness
it was the Epic of belief it was the
Epic of incredulity it was the season of
light it was the season of Darkness it
was the spring of Hope
it was the winter of Despair we had
everything before us and we had nothing
before us
and now I'll explain why we are in that
you know just hold on our gently but
yeah okay yeah it would be the other
door too to the office
no that's all right so at this time with
inflation higher than in nearly a
generation we had to ask our community
to fund 40 of our project
this particular line five on page two of
your bill that you've been reviewing
today
specifies that donations and grants
cannot be used
separate apart from the total cost of
the project to reduce the local taxpayer
contribution
earlier this week on Tuesday we had 700
people from our community we have a
thousand voters 700 came to our annual
school meeting we had divided them into
two large spaces that were available to
us our gym in our cafeteria
unfortunately our vote was not
successful
for this project however our budget and
our teacher Collective boarding
agreement did pass
the difficulty is
that 40 percent of our project is 6.5
million dollars and with a 15 year bond
at 5.25 we are speaking of on average
four dollars
per thousand
for our depressed community in Colebrook
and I mean that only in the way it's
described elsewhere I would never use
that term to describe our community
anywhere else but in a place where it
relates to our the economics of our
situation
so
um despite these challenges
um we have had more and more people come
forward and offer assistance so in
addition to the 60 million I'm sorry 60
um allocation from the Department
on February 7th we were offered a two
million dollar donation
from a graduate of co-work Academy
who has he's been identified in our
newspaper I'd rather not put them into
the record but he agreed to provide us
with a two million dollar donation if it
could be separate and apart from
the way that you're currently your
legislation reads which is
essentially it would have to be utilized
to reduce the overall project than
building a supply that's how the law
reads right now
because he would like would want it to
have the full 2 million
applicable to reducing taxpayers costs
not just a portion of it
following that we receive notification
that a local contractor was willing to
build this project for us at a savings
of 1.5 million dollars
then a few weeks later we were told that
the original donor was coming back and
offering another eight hundred thousand
dollars now we were down to about
3.1 million of you know again outside of
your formula 3.1 million of funds that
had not been collected still at all our
community did not feel that they could
take that on
unlike our CTE building projects where
75 Aid is provided and 25 match can come
from any source
198 15E which is also in your bill now
prohibits Aid recipients from
contributing to the local match
the language that's also contained in
the proposed in your proposed bill which
states that funds received from
charitable trusts bequests gifts
insurance policies federal grants or
grants from other state programs shall
be subtracted from the total project
costs when Computing grants under this
paragraph
our community is proud hard-working and
devoted to our children however they
have reached their economic limit their
total tax burden including the town the
school and the county is over thirty
dollars per thousand this year
it's really too much for them to take on
more taxable burden
however Coburg School District located
and so as we are in a isolated part of
the state we really are the center of
education for New Hampshire schools
and we have a 500 square mile School
District not to mention the many towns
that are surrounding us that are outside
of our district that also pay tuition to
send children to Colebrook schools
without this appropriation
in three years our tech building which
we're now leasing to Hauser Automotive
program will have to will have to be
closed that means we will have no place
for our auto program and our woodworking
program to be available
we have used a borrowed space from a
neighboring town in another school
district in a family consumer science
building to offer our culinary
Hospitality CTE program because we don't
have space in our building
I'm confident that if that particular
portion of the law could be changed or
removed
that funds receive from the travel cross
bequests gifts insurance policies grants
or grants from other state programs
can be struck so that we can
align them to our can remove them from
that computation and reduce our local
tax
obligation that we would be able to
receive sufficient money from donations
and grants to pay the entire remaining
of the amount of three million dollars
because of the way the law is written
right now we can't
do we have another chance of passing
this next year yes
I'm not certain that the our economy is
going to improve to the extent that
we'll be able to
that our taxpayers are going to be able
to find funds available in their own
personal finances to support it while
they do support the schools as I
mentioned in many ways
so my suggestions to you are this and
then I'll be quiet thank you for
listening to me for so long and this
even though we're not formally in a
hearing
first that you just strike that entire
section of the bill
which relates to the fund's charitable
trusts and great gifts and grants
or if that's a bridge too far in your
opinion consider adding a provision that
waives the requirement for school
districts eligible for 60 percent
building Aid which are those districts
like ours that are low income that have
a high percentage of Freedom reduced
lunch where our taxpayers are already
extremely burdened due to property taxes
as the primary way that we fund our
schools
lastly and this is probably the least
likely but um the another option you
might have and I've seen this in other
legislation if you don't support the
other two options I request that a
specific
statement be included that would exempt
Colebrook School District from this
particular provision so that we can get
on with building our school and making a
better future for the students in
Colebrook siu-7 and all the surrounding
communities in the North country
thank you very much
I included in my in your material you
had that testimony along with these
green handouts we have copies those up
here describe the CTE Center so that you
can see all of what's included and how
very exciting it is
um
we are we're devastated with a loss of
our vote
um I'm just not convinced that our
community can afford the remaining funds
the six million dollars that are
required in order to
make this project happen and um
it's not the I always look at it this
way
I'm coming in and I'm going to choke up
sorry
this is my 40th year of Education
like I'm sure many of you
um I came from a humble beginning and
um
it's not our kid's fault
that they were born in a community that
is poor
it's up to us to help them
to um
develop into people that are going to be
positive and contributing members of
society and have the skills that they
need to ensure that they will have a
positive life and can contribute to
their community
thank you thank you
not sure if it's appropriate
um
so
so part of my responsibility is that in
the in the school building authority I
was put in place because of my finance
background
um which I'm unable to use actually
um in my in my current position on the
school building authority
um we actually have two Finance people
we have the um on the board
we have the state treasurer and we have
myself
um
but neither of us and we struggle with
this
um speaking for myself anyway with what
what I deem to be my fiduciary
responsibility my goal as a as a finance
person is to always look for the clients
needs first not
for my needs
as such when I'm on the school billing
Authority I try to look for these states
interest
we're spending State taxpayers money is
the way I look at it and and I'm not
able to with the current setup with the
way our our scoring system and
everything it doesn't lend itself well
to individual stories it works great for
the
for the process as a whole
but individual parts of it
I think are failing
so
so I'm receptive to ideas that you have
in fact I welcome creative ideas
like carving out 60 percent
towns or or districts I also look at
carving out just for the sake of
argument
Colebrook if you look at the points
awarded under unsafe conditions for fire
safety infrastructural and blah blah
blah
um
that
speaks to me as well you know if we look
at that alone the the issue you just
brought up we also know in correct me if
I'm incorrect Amy that the there's an
emergency process that if a school is in
a situation where there is such an
emergency where you have issues of a
roof we're ready to fall in or if you
have yeah some of that basic building
code that we drafted into this
legislation years ago where it's
dependent upon the Fire Marshals uh
recommendations that uh that would take
precedent over some of the other
projects that are in line is that
correct
uh that's correct in the sense that
somebody that comes
um we haven't been in this process long
enough to develop a backlog list of
projects
um but if a project was to apply the
following year uh they can jump that
line otherwise they just get in line
four right now then on on this pay paper
and look at lines 15 going forward
before we get there just let me put on
the on the the record before we get off
the unsafe conditions yeah part of this
the it's no to me it's no coincidence
that the schools that are ranked one two
and three
all score the highest number of points
for
unsafe conditions yeah
so that's to me
um
telling me that it it's some somehow
Works to to Value those pieces but there
is no waiting other than the fact that
of the number of points that are
gathered in this on page four it has a
portion there which has been added into
452 which deals with the school building
authority
and on the bottom of of course if you
look at line 15 16 that's the emergency
projects that the commissioner can deal
with
but if you look down at line 28 29 30
going on to the other page and we're
talking about the school building
authority here what you shall or you
shall not do
School building authority shall verify
the ranking submitted by the
commissioner which comes to you and to
this point in time correct me if I'm
wrong Greg that you've been doing it
based on the criteria that you you that
they've been approved by Doe
but this would also say in accordance
with the criteria defined in
subparagraph 2B that's your
responsibility as the school building
authority elsewhere in statute
uh determine if the school district or
Charter Public School has the financial
means and available resources for school
building project
and make a written report of findings
and submit a list in descending rank
order to the State Board of Education
for approval
if you saw something that you felt was
being paid by other available resources
or they had the you know the financial
capability or they didn't have it you
could re-rank make a recommendation to
re-rank those and then it would come
back to the department for their work
I don't know if you've had to do that in
the past I I've not had to I've you know
this new language hasn't hasn't given us
the ability to do anything like that
um this this language I as I read it
would give us the ability to re-rank
based on that all we've had the ability
to now is is and I say this kind of half
tongue-in-cheek all I've been doing now
is checking Amy's math
um to make sure she's she's added up the
points correctly which is unsatisfactory
to me well you made a visit to Haverhill
and looked at the old building so you
did a lot more there in checking and I
did but getting to the timeline here
I'm not afforded that luxury on 17
projects or in and we can't
we can't get um
our our volunteer team basically
um of our part-time team or however you
want to call a bunch of volunteers to be
able to take the time to go to all 17
properties dealing with the State Fire
Marshal the treasury of the state the
commissioner of Education right we we
have things we have other things to do
now as I look at this let me show you
through a virtual meeting
um that that may be a a process as well
I mean that
um I will say even from the Haverhill
meeting if we had done just to pick your
school out even if we had done a virtual
meeting
it's not the same as walking as walking
the grounds yeah um
I
I really feel like we are
um rearranging the decks on the Titanic
here I I don't think
we we have the capability of changing a
few things and giving people different
Authority
I think we need a fundamental rethink of
it you mentioned some of those in the
beginning well we're going to get to
that okay we were just going to now the
the point being right now is that
anything we changed on this bill you're
not going to see any changes occur until
and if the governor signs it and if then
it's signed by September uh or or August
not to mention the funding right and and
yeah and we're dealing with that funding
right now
what's the uh the funding then dropped
down to Concord which is the next one
down
um so just so that we don't get
sidetracked I think if we just stick
with if I just stick with what
um
um superintendent I'm trying to I was
gonna call you representative so
superintendent Taylor was saying like I
think
um correct me if I'm wrong
um that what we're talking about right
now is on page two the funds received
from charitable trust it is just simply
staying whether we want that allowed to
be used as the local match
um so sixty percent forty percent the
town the community has to come up with
40 do you want that to be able to be
allow schools to use other resources as
their local match
um and the bill would be effective as
it's amended
um July 2023 so that would apply to all
the applicants that I have right now
um yeah it's the new ranking or a new
system that wouldn't apply to 2025. I
don't know what the purpose of this
original language was I don't know why
I'm either I think it's been in for a
while it was an attempt to
a little bit more than just a rubber
stand no no I don't mean that the the
added language I'm saying the the
um
the the
funds received from chapter since the
well I understand well maybe since you
were around I don't know but it um it
might be true but I do wonder what was
what is the difference if it's paid by a
donor or the taxpayers who are I agree
burdened it's not we're asking for any
more money I agree asking for another
nickel
I suspect it has to do with ownership
and you know when it you you've put
nothing into it well two things one is
the cost can be even higher you're not
necessarily as Frugal and two you don't
have the care and Etc when you have no
ownership and that may have been an
attempt
to make sure that the community was
committed
um
but but what difference would it make
to use Amy's phraseology
um whether this money that pays their
share
comes from any of these sources or comes
from the community I I don't I don't see
the point I'm not saying that I'm I'm
just saying I suspect that's where the
original
language came from was that concerned
I did this it was back when Duke
albany's and I wrote this thing
and that's many years ago at least well
so we're in a decade so let me ask you
um I have not in my time
on the board or on the authority no I
have not seen and and maybe Amy would
recall if there was ever a similar case
that's true but this language has been
in here even from old building Aid right
and this and it is part of our
calculation process almost everybody
receives some kind of donation or
federal mostly from energy rebate so on
our end we don't pay building Aid
um on anything and Energy rebates is
almost something all of our applications
come through with so we subtract that
off from the top and then we end up
applying the rate because of this law
um so all as that would say is that now
Energy rebates federal grants Esser
funds any of that money can be used as a
portion of their local match in order to
apply for building a whether you all
want to do that as a different
discussion but that's I think that
that's I think what the question is
right so
so
listing all of those items
this is my personal opinion I wouldn't
be thrilled about Esser funds going into
this I wouldn't be thrilled actually
about
um Energy rebates going into this
I would have no no problem however if it
in your situation having a local donor
um yeah or or
um an insurance policy a big Quest a
gift any of that doesn't make any damn
difference to me at all built their
hockey rink I understand this is what
I'm saying so I've never had a reason to
examine this yeah
but given your testimony
I have no reason to think that that
shouldn't be stricken from here those
lines yeah or at least some at least the
I do agree with you as far as Esther
grants and other rebates and yeah like
that we do have um some potential of a
northern borders commission Grant I'm
not sure if you're familiar with those
uh those are actually Federal flow
through funds specifically for depressed
parts of your state Southwest and
Northwest are the two areas that qualify
and they have infrastructure grants
which is another again it's unlike Esser
for quote it's not covet related at all
it's specifically to rebuilding
infrastructure in communities municipal
or schools and we've been in
communication with them and I believe
that that Grant would qualify but I also
understand what you're saying about the
others by doing what you're doing here
is there savings that you're not going
to have to send as many kids over to K N
for CTE you would keep them in your own
building we now have to spend 125
000 a year for tuition for those
students to go to their CTE Center and
they don't send anyone back to us
because of
um
I guess that they've told us it's
because their state doesn't allow them
to do so but I don't understand that
myself I've even that's the way it's
working all over the border at the five
CTE centers in Vermont we go there they
don't they don't come here yeah so
either way it's to us it's not we're not
looking for any more funds from the
state whatsoever it's just we'd like a
little flexibility and I like I said
we've already have nearly three million
dollars in donations and people have
been approaching me and saying they'd
like to contribute I'm certain that
within six months we could completely
cover that local cost
but it doesn't help us if we have to
ratchet down the overall cost because
you know I'd have to raise 16 million in
order for there should be no impact on
the taxpayers so I think what we can do
here is because we have a lot on the
docket here today but this component
right here we can address through the
amending language which we're proposing
if we can come up with something that
might work I kind of agree that some of
it may not be needed in this law uh so
we we can look at that and we act on
this next week there's still time to
that's why we're doing what we're doing
here right now understand though that
it's quite possible another two years or
from now this may be all pass a and
we're going through what we see as a
transitional step to maybe a
transitional step determining upon where
the pool money is going to come from and
and and who's going to have the
responsibility is it going to be the
local or is it going to be the state or
to what degree uh how do we account for
the difference is in communities like
your community has a huge difference
compared to Waterville Valley right
one last thing
um again Financial guy
um money is fungible so I I often wonder
whether there's not an opportunity for
um creativity in
um other other than targeting the
donation
to this project if there's not a
possibility of donating to
someplace else where money that donation
can go and that frees up money that can
be used outside of this language yeah
we've actually explored a lot of those
okay
the challenge is that this the way this
language is written you can't utilize
trusts or any other ways of paying for
this without taking it off the top
um and in order to do sort of a pay down
a kind of arrangement that's a poor way
of describing it we would have to borrow
the money first so that we would have
and use it as funds to pay it back I
understand we're represent Hill is
coming from though because I used to do
that with my school budget right the
district that if we can offset somewhere
else in our operating budget but the
money's coming in from somewhere else
then we can use those moneys possibly
because money is not targeted right and
and you utilize it over here our annual
operating budget is 7.8 million so we
don't have enough play in a budget that
small to make this kind of option but
you are right and looked at all of those
things but number one to do that we have
to have the borrow the bond has to be
approved then we can pay it down but
without the bond we wouldn't be able to
do that the other thing that I still
think needs to be examined
um and this
I promise you will take us off track but
I don't I I won't be far off
um CTE to me
needs to be looked at by districts
um
from a standpoint of whether you
um utilizing the existing rsas and uh
and having school districts authorize a
charter school
um similar to spark Academy and in
Manchester authorized a charter school
use the startup charter school money
um for CTE and utilize the 100 funding
from for charter schools and and and
segregate your your CTE from the
district I guess
um previous in a previous District
outside of New Hampshire I did something
similar it was a small Alternative High
School program and in that state you
were able to integrate your your Charter
into your public school it's not the
same here in New Hampshire but the
difficulty is we don't have space
and right now the charter school
legislation doesn't allow building Aid
to be considered it's 100 to pay for
your operating expenses but not to build
so we wouldn't be able to do that here
in this particular case although I'm
would be I don't think our community
would be opposed to that option if we
had a place to locate the programs so
maybe and and this is so maybe those
that donation money can can utilize or
or locate a a suitable building
you know this is this is all part of the
moving the pieces around until it fits
you know um if you just a thought I'd
love to have you visit we had to close
our high school because
safe very old a lot of uh issues that
would have cost probably 30 million to
repair it wasn't a worthwhile investment
for us
there are no other buildings in the town
has has commissioner edelblue visited
he has visited not recently I think
probably about maybe a year and a half
ago he has he has uh an interesting
story
um
on
a donor
that uh in Manchester I think it was
that was willing to build a school
um
and and virtually lease it back to the
community and the school would and the
district would own the school at the end
of 30 years or something like that and
Manchester turned it down which seemed
the silliest Choice I've ever heard ever
um
but it may be something that you would
like to have a conversation with him
about and see if there was someone else
that with with the available money that
in the North country that you've already
somewhat mentioned or the opportunities
for credits I cannot I can't believe
something like that wouldn't be off on
top of it would it be as I said in the
beginning a stroke of your pen eliminate
this entire section or revise it to
allow for the use of charitable trust or
donations I wouldn't be a post that
would be that would solve our problem
immediately and we like I said we only
have three years as you know it takes a
year to prepare to break ground and
you're breaking ground until next summer
so can data be developed to illustrate
any pattern of affect there may be with
potential donors who pulled out of
something because of or whatever it
seems to me that
it's absolutely wrong-headed to penalize
the person needing the help because
somebody else is willing to help them
too to accept that you know we're going
to take it away and give it to somebody
across the street uh that that isn't the
way donors work in my experience what
what's the the vote you had you didn't
get the votes you needed is that a
result that folks feel that the CTE
Center came and is still providing the
adequate needs for their kids
no because our CTE Center is very
different is uh no none of the programs
are duplicated
um and when we received a girl from the
Department about the last year to
initiate our CTE program we had three to
four hundred people in our
cafeteria to speak to commissioner
edelblue and explain how strongly they
supported the CTE concept so I can say
unequivocally that there is huge support
for the CTE the problem we are having is
inflation by costs for food for fuel for
and of course our our income is already
depressed amongst are you receiving any
Carl Perkins money
well because we just opened this year no
but next year we will and the Carl
Perkins amount that they had been giving
to Kanan will come to us I don't know
what the final allocation is but it's in
the realm of around 30 to 40 000 per
year so then it sounds like if it's not
going to go to Canaan you're not going
to be sending more kids to Keenan
well that's a complicated discussion
because supposedly they're an approved
New Hampshire region one Center and we
are obliged by law to send allow
students to attend any Center they
choose to attend
regard if they're approved so even
though they don't send as you mentioned
students to ours
as I said their programs we have only
about eight or so students going there
now the numbers have really declined
because the programs they've had just
aren't of interest to our students we
have automotive technology which
includes Powersports
and that's our area right it's all about
repairing power sports equipment and
diesel mechanics in that one program we
have a teacher education program because
we have a very difficult time bringing
new teachers into our region and we have
a lot of our own students who are
interested in beginning that career
and that's in partnership with white
mountain and Plymouth we also have a
Health Sciences program which our
hospital is a very strong partner with
and that enables our students to get
experience not just as lnas but all
kinds of career Fields right now we have
five students graduating three want to
become Physicians
your hospital is a uh I'll shoot up
Hitchcock right
no it's uh offshoot of the Berlin it's
um well it's not part of Dartmouth
Hitchcock no
okay opportunity upper Connecticut
Valley Hospital ucbh it's not particles
if we were to strike charitable property
questions and insurance policies from
that line
and solve yours issue
no problem
okay
okay good
so let's roll on here we can't guarantee
anything but you know you've made your
case thank you very very much I
appreciate your time thank you thank you
enjoy the trip back to Pittsburgh yes
well I'll be stopping at the office
first okay thank you
going through this you can see the
comments I have in various places and
the but the primary reason for this
because I want to get on some other
things to discuss today is that we need
to clear up a few areas within it that
we had there prior I also have to find
out what you think about this section on
the school building authority but the
timeline is imperative that we get
something in place or timeline what this
time can you explain what the timeline
does for us now Amy meaning that what
this would happen if this were to well
for future applications even if it's
just for the next two years how's that
going to help both groups here right so
essentially again building a changes in
the future you know that is a probably a
separate conversation but for this what
it what this does mostly for me and the
school districts is it allows them to
not apply a year in advance it actually
uh requires them or allows them to apply
um many months later and so they're
essentially applying if it were this
year they would be applying right now
that's a good way to look at it is they
would be applying right now then the
state budget would come out in the next
couple of months and then they would get
ranked this fall
um and then they could know where they
stand on the list but most importantly
they would know how much commitment they
can have from the state maybe it's none
maybe it's some then they are able to go
to their warrant their voters with an
amount right now they're not
um Colebrook and all the others on the
list just went to their voters without
having any idea of money that's going to
be appropriated or not so pushing that
timeline out
further out allows them to apply right
now get that determination by this fall
go to their voters in the Spring and
most importantly if their voters say yes
then they can start construction when
they need to in the spring
um
your this current timeline we have right
now misses out on so many things but it
misses out on getting the voters to know
what they're voting for but it also
misses out on the
um construction season because July 1st
they find out how much money if they're
going to get any then they've already
they can't start song they say can't
start construction this summer they have
to wait all the way and all of those
costs get messed up so this amendment
for timeline wise addresses that which I
think is the main problem there might be
other issues but I think that that is
the State Board of funds by November
15th
right and if you put it in terms of this
year because it's easier from I think
for all of us to understand because
we're right now talking about the state
budget it would mean that November 1st
of this year they would have a
commitment from the state
um on how much they would be awarded for
a building Aid
so then it goes before the voters in in
next march in the following March and
then they can start construction in June
so once their kids get out of school for
some of them anyway that would be a
benefit to them and then it also repeats
that every year I think
um we've talked about this before
um
well building Aid is just unstable in
the sense of knowing how much money is
going to come and I I am uh
I I worry that schools are making a
decision uh on a project that maybe they
have embedded fully through their
Community or you know because it's this
one chance that they get versus having
to reapply the following year
um because then if they get voted down
well then they can just
listen to their voters and figure out
what project can really pass and apply
next year rather than waiting two years
to apply and then apply a year in
advance the way it is right now it's a
long timeline our current timeline
and it causes a lot of uncertainty so
for me the big problem I well there's a
number of big problems that timeline is
is horrendous
one or the proposed one
I'm not I'm not
qualified to talk on the proposed one is
yeah
some of the some of the problems that I
see is timing is everything in this part
of it is
um
who who else is applying in the same
year that you are
um some of this is you know the luck of
the draw here of you know you may be in
a I mean I forget how many were in the
process no the year before uh five
yeah so
you see what I'm saying um if you're you
know one of 17 versus 105
um and you're submitting the same amount
of money into building Aid
um you got to like your chances when
you're one of five more so than when
you're one of 17.
but also struck in here is this idea of
um
you know some schools applying for you
know 170 million and some schools
applying for 13 million
um you know if you're looking at how
many lives you change you can do a lot
of those 13 million dollar projects for
the kind of like the discussion we've
had with with public school
infrastructure
um you know
is it is it fair that we don't do 13
million dollar projects for
um schools like Holbrook when
um one project in Concord sucks up you
know 170 million
um it's part of the conversation that we
have to have where money is that we have
a cap that's of money the next ticket
here on that on the DACA today is to
look at that particular concept the
other thing I wanted to look at is that
so let's say we we approved this year
the the Colebrook and uh
Monadnock is it that yeah we also hit
the Rochester correct
what about the ones just down below do
they automatically go to the top of the
list or are they still on the list and
have to compete with other schools which
may come on the list over the course of
the next year
yes that's isn't it that's it
so
two things one you have to remember is
so important to remember this when
you're talking about projects like
Concord and others what you see in front
of you is their request not what they're
eligible for all schools are eligible
for cost per square foot per pupil
so you know there I think there's a lot
of validity in saying a big school might
be
um a rebuild of a big school might be
getting an opportunity like how can we
fund that smaller renovation project
those are in my opinion valid
conversations because they're hard to
get to those those re like smaller
projects at the bottom of the list
because they don't rank as high I think
that is a problem how does somebody that
just wants to put um a secure vestibule
on their building how do they compete
with a brand new rebuild because they're
in the same competing but when you just
talk about all
um full rebuilds or full new schools
then you're really talking about a cost
per square foot per pupil and what what
the list it takes time for us to review
those plans and determine their
eligibility and we can't do that as a
state one big because it's only me but
number two is that the we don't know
right now no funding is going to those
schools so how much resources do we put
into reviewing those applications
um so just keep that in mind when
there's a big request uh whether it be
Concord or or others on the list it's
it's likely that a lot of their ask is
not going to be eligible for building
Aid they play against the same rules as
the other schools that are building
other school districts
um so Amy do they automatically go to
the top of the list so yeah sorry uh yes
they know they do not currently they
would if they're
um which I think is another problem in
the next biennium those 17 projects will
only stay on the list if they're voters
pass but the state did not have enough
funds which in theory sounds good if all
of the those schools went to their Town
vote then you'd kind of get a read but
the reality is a lot of those schools
are so far down the list that they're
just assuming that they're not going to
get building AIDS so they've either
they've either Knicks their project
altogether
um and maybe some communities have gone
forward without the other 14 Schools
gone to their voters I think there are
some we'll see as these schools start to
have their meetings but we'll know at
the end of the month whether they'll
have some that have gone we've heard
about we don't haven't tracked all their
how many of those
on this list I mean essentially if
you're below number five I I don't I
don't think that those schools are
really even thinking that they're going
to get any kind of building Aid that was
the other side of that there's always
the other side of that coin because
um two-year two well one session ago my
school district
um ended up on the top of the list and
went to the voters and the voters said
no so
um it doesn't
you know
um it's it's just not a guarantee
um and I've pointed out all the time
without having the assurances of whether
the voters actually want this
it's somewhat unfair
to make
the state evaluate all of these projects
when we know virtually some of them
aren't aren't going to the process
aren't going to go to the process
there must be a lot of man hours in that
women hours and on that too yeah
um it is
good it's good it's also good in my
opinion for the Department of Education
to understand understand those project
needs to and be in school buildings and
understand those projects so they've
certainly not wasted hours of being in
those 17 buildings what is wasted hours
is the school districts that have spent
money on these applications in time they
are difficult applications to put in
when they have no idea what kind of
funding is available which again pushing
that timeline helps
um
you know I was brainstorming this
morning on a alternative idea explain
your brainstorm and I don't know it
really is just a brand new idea today so
um
the way lisaid works which is a portion
of
um of 195 198 15 it's for
um
we saved payments for Charter Schools is
that it funds everybody on the list but
it takes how much is available that was
appropriated and takes and prorates
everybody that would not work under the
current scenario because we don't know
um they're applying so well in advance
and we don't know how much is
appropriated but with a timeline like
this it could work I mean I think it
could work
um
where you know how much money people
apply you get your pool of applicants
and then you prorate everybody it would
do a couple of things that I think would
be good is it would Target those smaller
projects and note they would no longer
have to compete we would not have to
rank projects that would be
um I think a something if you are
wondering like you could spread out the
30 to 60 percent you could really
stretch that
um 20 to 80. you could that way your
communities start at 20 but then they
get prorated based on how much Aid was
actually approved and maybe they're only
going to end up with a 15 award but then
those communities that are more at the
higher end maybe they're 60 communities
or 70 communities and maybe after
proration they only get 55 or 65 percent
Aid
um it would be a way to kind of stretch
that out the other thing that would be
important in that scenario would be that
a lot of those votes wouldn't pass and
you wouldn't be able to make changes on
the fly like oh no now we are able to
give you a little bit more instead you'd
have to make that money fall into the
next year for the next category for the
next proration amount
um so with that you'd still have to have
a timeline where they're applying like
now meaning the the time that the budget
is being talked about you'd still have
to give them the amount that they were
prorated at so that they know how much
to go to their voters for and that would
stretch out money to reach everybody
so I don't know if that is even an idea
to consider but just putting it out
there
I think it needs more fleshing out yes
from oh absolutely now because what it I
can see I can you know almost instantly
think of
unintended consequences but I guess they
are uh with it may mean if if we had
that kind of a scenario there may people
may have looked at it and said Gee we're
going to get money under some money and
so now instead of 17 applications you
had 54 applications or something like
that you know it may encourage because
they know if they apply as they
understand it it would just be spread
out by how many applications yeah
refund it and your prorate maybe right
you get a buck well then keep in mind
that you still would have to be eligible
for building Aid right I mean there's a
lot of things that aren't still
evaluation it would yeah I wouldn't say
I mean it's still building Aid it's
still eligibility and another thing that
I'm not sure that a lot of people know
is that you can't re-apply for building
aid for a 35 40 year window so
um so you can't just keep putting in
applications you can't build a new space
thing of it as like credits you you are
you get a square foot per person for per
student that you get credited uh this is
all done on paper but you get credited
and if you come in for a building later
on and you've used your credits up then
you you're that isn't eligible for Billy
Aid
um
so if you another example we do have an
application
um you know you've bought you built a
wing in 2010 that gets taken out of new
construction and renovation be in the
same pot ooh good question
well our Renovations are when we talk
about Renovations we talk about full gut
Renovations that's what's eligible for
building Aid and a lot of what's the
percentage of building new is it 25 or
you know so you can declare something as
a a new construction if the cost of
renovating exceeds a certain percentage
60 but that really just means you need
to submit extra documentation okay so in
uh and honestly renovation costs are
sometimes more expensive than new costs
what what I think if you needed to if
you wanted to separate separate
different categories you wouldn't do
renovation and new
um you would more do big full rebuilds
or re-renovations guts
um or the small projects like uh okay
Monroe they're a vestibule project
that's a vestibule project so that would
be a renovation project correct or
whatever oh that's a new that's an
addition it's an addition it's part
edition part renovation
yeah so the problem is they can't
compete because they're getting security
points but they're not getting other
points on on their list they're not
getting consolidation points they're not
getting you know
um so that's the the the the Crux behind
my asking you that renovation projects
may not have all those extra points but
certainly for that one area
they're lacking it might be safety only
safety but when we talk about renovation
a good example Salem is a renovation I
mean that's a renovation project
um Salem they were on the list last year
Salem and Allenstown were selected for
building Aid uh Allen Santa's new school
and Salem was a
Renault with new space but they are I
mean it's like wall to walls takings
back down to the studs when a renovation
has to in building a terms it has to
meet the criteria called substantial
renovation and those are
um they are bringing the building up to
like new conditions
um first is a renovation where you might
think with a vestibule really they're
renovating they have to move their admin
spaces to make accommodations for their
new vestibule
um that is a different project than a
substantial renovation project we'd
consider that an addition project okay
the next part we really ought to get
into here is the second part of the
amending language and this gets into the
concept or the idea are we moving
towards another process whatever it
might be whether we're flat funding or
whether we're putting it totally on the
local or whatever we may be doing how do
we get to that point how do we Wade
through all these various ideas that
I've heard on the floor you know there's
a number of folks saying isn't there a
better way you know I'm never going to
get something here given the way the
formula is set up so if you look on the
one
did I pass this sheet out to everybody
the amending language one with just the
amending language no Okay so
there there's a copier two and
here
you might give one to uh Alicia and to
Jen
just as a real quick go through here the
education commission the state says now
we're getting into the question uh we
asked Jennifer asked for me do you asked
for information about how States fund
Capital Construction
and we did get this page back it looks
like this or has the yellow marks on it
and and you can see that there's a
number of ways which are done uh
um there and there's examples for States
here
um
it gives you some of the percentages and
what states do what there's also another
sheet which I've handed you
uh which is
it looks like this right here and it
says well okay they do it through
where's the money come from sales tax
that's how uh Georgia
yeah Iowa Virginia then you go to
Lottery uh that's uh North Carolina
uh these are just examples of States
state general funds then you see Ohio uh
excise taxes Colorado there's and and
there's additional ways of doing it as
well that's informational for you
um so that this is gonna this is part of
the discussion which is in this amending
language the amending language has the
Amendments we just spoke of with uh
superintendent Taylor but you can see on
this amending language one on page two
and three
this would be there would be added to
this
this amending lines for 452 to establish
the committee long-term sustainable
funding formula for school building a
and it would be comprised of uh
committee members it's not a commission
this will be a committee
and the committee shall on lines 22
going on down do those various things
um and I I put it out here because it
we're really I'm open and I think the
committee's open to try and find out
what do we really want to do
the on line 23 on page two it says study
methods of ensuring long-term
sustainability funding for school
buildings and identify any source of
such funds
where is the money coming from that's
always an issue B consider whether the
state's percentage share of a building
Grant age should be a flat funded amount
same percentage for all other words or
allocated based upon a weighted Equity
criteria conditions such as Local
District wealth and income we take that
into account now grade levels associated
with the project the elementary middle
geographic location project it projected
demographics on and on the list can go
see it's an exam examine the fiscal
impact benefits on the state and local
districts relative to dispersing the
state allocation share at the beginning
of the project through payments then or
spreading them out over the term of the
bond
this is just working sort of with the
formula which we would have if the
currently
um study IMD study program eligibility
criteria and process for prioritizing
ranking School building a grants that's
looking at our whole process whether
that's correct or not
examine other state school building Aid
programs to determine how those states
are funding capital outlay for new
construction and renovation projects
F determine the need for a Statewide
facility condition assessment to better
know prioritize and project anticipate a
10-year Capital expenditures related to
school building 8 program
G review the building aid application
process to ensure prioritization of
facility Improvement goals clearly at
that that clearly identify the
relationship between facility
utilization and operational program
objectives of the school study any other
issues related to school building aid
grant procedures that it deems relevant
solicit testimony for any any individual
or Association that has information on
it
there are so many
ideas floating out there this is going
to have to be a committee that would
do that it can be done on the side with
a task force it could be done through
Doe it could be done on the side by a
group of people huddling together and
and saying well here's here's a proposal
where they submit it in the form of
their own legislation
and that may happen
there are it's there there's you know
down the southern part of the state
there are people who want to get
reimbursed of all the things they built
um that ain't gonna happen
um hope not yeah so here we are how do
we how do we go to that next step I'm
asking Greg you've been on the school
building authority and you've
communicated me often some of the
concerns and issues that you've seen and
and and that we need to address I've
done the same thing and Amy's done the
same thing too we are the squeaky Wheels
um I think it's interesting
that it seems you know to all things of
the season I think it seems that
um School building Aid has we've been
squeaking enough that um it's now almost
reached a fever pitch and we start
hearing those same things in a number of
different
meeting rooms here we have to do
something with school building Aid what
well I don't know but I think that there
are a number of
behind the scenes processes going on and
I think we will see
whether it's this year or next
um
new proposals coming out we just heard
one today
um you know well that was uh it's just a
a nighttime dream I understand that's
but that's where these things come from
and
um personally
I'm not a fan of committees I don't
think this approach will will come out
with our solution I I so I've just seen
enough how do we get to where I think
what let me get it coordinated I think
uh we are I don't know if it's
coordination this is the solution
um I think what happens is
um there's a number of really bright
people when you have 426 people
um in a hive
knocking into each other which is I
think one of the benefits of us being
here instead of being on Zoom
um I think lots of different ideas start
percolating I think that's why in the
last couple years we didn't see a lot of
new ideas come along but but we are I've
I've heard five or six that people have
asked that talked about already
so my guess is the process is happening
without
this kind of a I belong to two different
groups already that are ad hoc that are
looking at ways of doing something
different
I think that's where the solution is
going to come from much more so than
this because I've never seen for
instance a school choice committee that
comes out with any kind of a
um acceptable school choice but we've
seen five or six different school choice
options come through legislation that
just percolated from individual
ad hoc committees so that's what I think
will happen
as much as I recognize the work that
you've done in this to get here I I
personally don't see not a lot of work
there it's a string you know that that
made us two hours it seems to me that
the core requirement needs to be a
database that we can all access with the
same eyes
in other words if we did an assessment
Statewide of the condition of the
schools and therefore from that when
they're likely to need Improvement
replacement addition whatever we could
make that assumption from that database
and then you can start looking at where
are you going to need to put money
and you have you'll have some concrete
data about look it's only going to last
17 years so this is when it Bears out
needs to be fixed or repaired or
whatever I think that's true except
you're assuming
that the solution that may come out of
some other program
is is going to include the state
funding of those Solutions you may be
one additional step is what I'm saying
yeah I think most of the people in the
state also are assuming that well um
whether or not they should it's another
old question right it is true I I do
think that there are a number of people
that
that assume that and then you ask
why is it we don't do state
um building for fire and safety and and
they say yeah that's true why don't we
you know so it is
I think there is a larger issue
I do agree that that would be helpful if
that existed now
um and Amy has done some of that work
um you know we've we've scratched out
numbers of how many schools there are
and how long as they live and all of
that kind of stuff and come out with a
rough estimate but
um
again there's a fundamental question of
how involved does the state need to be
in that issue first and then and then
you Branch off that decision tree I
perhaps may be reacting to my uh cold
prayers with the other persuasion who
always go to the status quo
and they consider that the status quo is
going to continue forever
and so I may be overreacting to that
anticipation well the status quo has not
continued here we've been through a
moratorium there's been no quote uh so
here we are now we have situations where
we have buildings which were built a
hundred years ago that just aren't
cutting it or in of course then you have
the other one saying well they're only
half full so you know figure it out well
which is another big piece of this I
mean it
um built into that structure
into that conversation and I didn't hear
it on you in your bill but somewhere in
there we need to look at these from that
though that prism of
what do these buildings turn into if
we're no longer going to have sufficient
students to fill all of them
um
I know whenever we have schools before
the school building a uh Authority
generally it's Frank that says what else
can this building be looked at and have
you looked at what it can be converted
to is it an assisted living facility can
it be you know something else well I was
trying to say the largest growing
demography
I'm there
um but I think uh I I think there's a
lot of big pieces it's going to be
almost impossible I got to believe to
have a s a single document solve every
issue I I I just can't see that
happening
um this there's there's how many schools
in 600 roughly or four to six hundred
yeah um I think there's four to six
hundred different solutions
um is is the what I'm see on page six of
this first document we looked at there
was a comment I made on the side
and the comment reads discussion item uh
offset costs a new construction colon
sale amount of previous property or use
but you know so where where does the
revenue come from the sale of that
property is that go back into new
construction
um offset the bond or what it's another
part of that question isn't it um does
you know
to me all of these things are somewhat
linked
um you know a a charter school is a
public school
um the public built these traditional
Public Schools even if it was a hundred
years ago
um
somewhere there's a linking that those
children in that traditional public
school that are that may be now
transition to a charter school should
have equal access to that same building
um I'll take write my own home Community
right now we have the grade school the
elementary school in Woodsville which is
an older building it's still usable if
they can renovate parts of it but it's
right across from Walmart
on 302 and Route 10 right at the
intersection
as Prime commercial property yep so if
they decide to raise that building tear
it down
what are they going to get in return for
if they sell that property off
um would that be then used to towards
the new aren't there there's existing
rsas on that right for for or in your
Charter School your your Charter see if
they don't want to go to the Charter
School no no no I mean if they're oh
well so they want to use that that's a
different story but if inside your your
document somewhere along the line and I
understand there's school districts that
don't have because yours is a
Cooperative as well
well that's a Cooperative of one town
yeah but but inside there is a document
for that
somewhere that's because it does say
what happens when you sell that property
or it should
I I'd have to go look at yeah I know
because we brought I think that's
questions already in this road and use
those portable classrooms at Woodsville
Elementary School and those Portables
really weren't worth dragging across the
street yeah uh but it raises the
question so if they want to sell that
property off to offset the costs of the
bond
can you can you I don't know I would
look at your internal documents first
well you're the school building
authority you're supposed to be checking
oh
near the million this this work session
is great and I appreciate that yeah but
there are a million little questions let
me ask a question Amy of you here
um so there's a number of ways that we
can try to coordinate this so we don't
get a lot of disjointed type proposal
coming in
legislative wise that haven't been
thoroughly thought out and that's our
job to filter through all that there
needs to be a coordinating
organization that to me would be the
State Board of Education or the
Department of Education
if you're going to set up some kind of
like you do with curriculum a task force
to look at how we're teaching
mathematics and social studies would it
not be better to have rather than a
committee that the department uh set up
some kind of a a process where we're
going to start looking into sort of like
you you've done with these minimum
Public School standards
um you you had that you contracted that
service out is it there's you wouldn't
have to necessarily do this unless you
know you didn't have the time for that
but were to look at where is this
present building School building aid
process working can we tweak this to
make it work better we can do some of
that right here we will this this
timeline has to be done but is are there
a number areas in there that are just
not doing what we wanted to totally do
right now partially do the way we're
funding it and it's the funding process
correct all that should be discussed but
is it better done through the department
uh you know that's probably a good
question for the commissioner
um but my guess is that he probably
think would think that that's a good
idea I know from other conversations
that he's already thinks that it's
important for other conversations to
come about about how building Aid can
can be functioning
um and thinking outside the box is
definitely his his favorite thing to do
as well that maybe it'd be a that's the
appropriate way to get this thing done
and done you know
quickly that could start right now right
I think it's going on right now so I
think um having that you know I
whether our study committee comes up or
not
um I think that that probably process is
going through and my preference is to
work with the department and not have
another committee right the speaker of
the house does not want any more
committees right so Rick I know
I heard what uh Greg was saying
and I know that there are numerous
people talking about putting bills and
whatever might it make sense to use all
of that legislative creativity but have
like a
whether it's a clearing house that's
what I was thinking Clearinghouse and
then I was thinking or just a keeper
like a conference or a so you know a day
for that set up somewhere for them to
all come together and say hey this is
this is what I'm thinking this is my you
know it's hardly actually submit bills
or I think something I think that's a
hard I I hear what you're saying
it's a hard thing to have people sitting
listening to
all you know 14 different concepts
because you will like one piece out of
each of them and and you really end up
nowhere
um where you still need is that
individual con
from that what I would see is someone
walking down the hall and saying hey I'm
gonna steal that piece that you had on
this
um would you support it in my idea of
doing this which is how
right lots of legislation occurs it
certainly is and that's why I wasn't
sure what form it should take but a form
not as a final coming up with a final
but just some way of getting all of
these people planning these bills to
hear what other people are planning so
they can do just exactly that oh that
would work right in here right well what
you're seeing is a piece of that
here right now in this kind of a work
session and that's where I I kind of
disagree that it should be done through
the department
I although I I'm not
um opposed to that because I belong to a
one or two of those but yeah but it is I
do think that you have a role here too
um the chair in House and Senate
to have a work session or two and bring
in one or two people with ideas and and
discuss those but see there's there's
the commission process like public
school infrastructure but that's not
going to hack it that's not going to do
it uh we I I like that the idea of it
being
the gatekeeper or the Clearinghouse
really belongs with the Department of
Education or the State Board of
Education or somebody that's linked to
it I don't think so I don't think so
either I I well there's going to be
somebody that's going to keep this
moving well I think that's the
legislature yeah because part of the
problem are you do have somebody assign
that responsibility you could do a
subcommittee just like a work session
just like we're doing here
put it out publicly and say hey all you
guys who are looking at ideas this is
the date we're going to do this come and
share your ideas
that's what I meant by conference or
whatever just a chance for people to sit
down at the same time I think if you
have the doe be the
the gatekeeper
um
it's hard in some cases for the doe or
the people in the doe to have the same
blunt conversations that we're have that
ability to communicate and say our ideas
we've certainly done it here today well
that's what we're saying yeah right
yeah see well yeah we we could continue
to do it in a form like we have here and
just keep that process going and then
and then run it by and then bring in
Frank and say hey what do you think of
that we'd have to have meetings posted
and we would you know work sessions and
we'd have to have you know we'd
certainly we'd have to have need for
technical support along the way it
doesn't necessarily have to be a
formalized process it doesn't have to be
formalized this is really not formal
here no but I um
is you can imagine
if this room was full
um of the usual characters here we
wouldn't be having the kind of same
conversation that we're having now no
because she'd have hope different
perspectives but but you would be having
um
you would be having side conversations
you would be having all kinds of things
that it's not as productive as small
informal groups mainly because a lot of
the people who are here have other
priorities that for them transcend the
ones that we're talking about well if
their idea is what will this do to the
number of people employed to do this and
this and that and in this Union and that
Union and so forth could be their
priorities will be there oh I can
guarantee it yeah well I think we've got
to be very careful in that you know the
they will have ownership in their ideas
yes but that's what you want to hear
because if we're going to get to where
we are going to have something that's
going to have some longevity we gotta we
got to know that right but if you have
that diversity of ideas yeah
it's hard for that type of group to come
into a focus of of legislation that's
why we don't go to reps Hall and do
legislation in reps Hall we do
legislation on your computer and my
computer and then we come and testify
and try to get consensus that I think
you have to have some initial part where
you can have different ideas coming
forward without one idea being squelched
and another person bullying this idea
forward
then what we got to do is try to get a
process of whittling it down like you're
doing an interview you might have 25
people interview for a job you want to
get it down to five yeah then you're
going to pull those five in then you
Whittle it down maybe to three or two
then you have to make the final decision
so if we ever written legislation like
that pardon me how have we ever written
legislation yeah it's it's that's no
that's management that's that no but you
have an example of of this is a whole
new thing for for what you're describing
and maybe it may be idyllic always
before we've always brought a
boilerplate forward and so we're going
to work off the boilerplate we brought
the last goal around in this when I did
it we borrowed some stuff from Maine and
we brought people in and we started
writing this and also basing off what Ed
Murdo had in the past over here at
Department of Education right and they
were basically nobody everything but I'm
saying um even let's take some big
project like the EFA project
um that didn't we didn't all sit in a
room
and get Divergent ideas and get those
top five but that doesn't work concept
that was new but that's something that's
going to need to be the same thing but
it's still dealing with the same topic
the brick and mortar of a school we need
a new A New Concept just like the EFA
was why do we need a totally new there
see you're already working like this how
do you know it's not working it's
working for those that got
that's not missing for mostly so it has
some issues to have to be fixed or or we
have to retune the whole thing
but we it's we're still dealing with the
same topic well this age-old talk to
Schoolhouse I can show you back in 1887
when the commissioner education said
it's one of our top priorities
well efas were dealing with education
it's the same topic yeah totally new way
of doing it
and I think there are things that uh you
know
I do think you need
um input from look this this project
that Frank put together or or discussed
for Manchester that this public private
partnership
um oh
that's a whole concept that that needs
to be fleshed out and and could be
submitted as legislation if if
legislation isn't needed
um I don't think it was for Manchester
it was it was floated to Manchester and
Manchester rejected it
but that's a whole I understand that
it's
within the building Aid realm but it's a
whole new idea of how to provide school
buildings to a community or or
locate all kinds of things so
it is a new idea to take Alicia's
comment be because you first have to
decide whether you're going to
tweak an existing state-funded state
directed State coordinated process or
you're just going to enable
districts to do something and and
Innovative and and show them different
ways of making that happen it's kind of
like the risk pool idea that we came up
with for special ed funding that is a
different idea and just enabling them to
do that and that was coordinated through
whom
foreign
well
well yeah well yeah he was very much
involved with it you were involved with
it uh no I understand uh you're I'm
using it as an example of I just think
that you know you need somebody that's
going to give you some support from the
management of the whole process
to that's one way and to ensure that
it's going to move forward that it's
moving forward constructively we're
we're getting different focuses for
different perspectives but and we're
also having meetings called and somebody
has the responsibility for scheduling
meetings all that the management is
important can be and or else you can
just do it totally on the side but then
you lose that air of transparency of
that sounds more like end process than
beginning process when you're
brainstorming and we're really in
brainstorming part brainstorming no
ideas or bad ideas right everybody just
puts them out there
so you do some brainstorming first and
let every all those people with their
ideas like uh Daniel papavichi Mueller
was from and he's on finance too and he
he's got a completely different idea of
how to fund School building Aid right
and and there are other people who have
other completely different ideas so you
do the brainstorming because that's how
you come to Solutions is you start with
brainstorming and you put all the ideas
out there and and and when you put them
out there you don't judge any of them
yeah and taking that same scenario I've
already met with him and he's saying
what kind of technical support can you
give me in this whole process to better
understand something so that's exactly
what we're looking for you can't do it
in isolation you're going to have to get
the support from Amy or from Frank or
from you sometimes the transparency that
you talk about
is is far further down further down the
road normal the formal yes it's later
down the road but you're still at the
beginning you need to have a working
administrative type group of some kind
that's going to be able to coordinate
this and try to get it all together
and then you then you're going to have
to go through the process a more open
process but you have a working group
and I I think that's what we have to
have is now how do we form a working
group now as a legislature that we can't
do we can do it by way commission or
committee or we can have work sessions
how do we end up having this meeting
well I decided we're going to have to
have a meeting right put it in the
calendar got this based on a bill based
upon a bill or even if this bill hadn't
been here I would have done it exactly
exactly so you do the same thing a
person could be you
could be it could be you
says we're going to have this working
session ask her to come and that gives
us her input so all these people who
come with their ideas can ask it's the
research partion but there's a downside
to that too you have people that may
come to this kind of a meeting with
microphones on and taping
that don't want to say things
um that jeopardize their own Community
right
which may be why some add ad hoc type
approach look at the funding commission
we just did
yeah what that was a a half a million
dollars funding and
did we have all those services available
here in this building
where we wouldn't have had to pay what
we paid out to car seat and everything
yes we got right back there in the back
left Empire research that's our research
right and that research can be used by
that group in other words there there's
going to be times when we have to get
further than just the
uh right but we have other research
um
Alternatives yes electric Slater but
this is a research that because
ultimately down the road we're hoping to
make some legislation right which would
move us forward but most of the
legislation I I think does not come from
a work session and and and open and
transparent
conversations I think most legislation
comes from in the hall talking to your
buddy yep or in the cafeteria or in the
cafeteria and awful lot comes from there
well there's a lot that comes the other
way too in fact I look at the bills this
committee has passed out this year and
most of that came through a lot of deep
work with other committees and and I'm
not saying it came outside I'm saying
this you you you have to understand that
there are pluses and minuses of both
approaches there are and and so I don't
think it's necessary that you create one
pathway for this bill for this ID these
ideas to be fleshed out when you're
giving up some alternative no all the
other stuff is going on concurrently I
think so too yeah but then we've got to
get all these all these parts put
together somehow that's where you need
to have that person that's going to call
this together and say okay we're working
on that now you you come up with your
thoughts and ideas and praying we're
gonna have this General discussion this
is where I always thought OLS had
another
could have another responsibility which
would be beneficial when they sit down
with one attorney like he used to sit
with Anthony and you could say here's my
idea for doing this and Anthony could
turn and say have you talked with you
know Dan McGuire because he has a
similar uh you know I always thought
there was a way of of being a connecting
system and they do have research too
that should go a little farther and then
you know you can go over to the archives
right I've gone that whole route me too
yeah and and it's there's a lot more
than we do than just with the Anthony's
or the Jefferson no and we do need
somewhere along the line because you and
I aren't going to be here forever there
needs to be well I'm not going to be
here forever there may be we need to
have some way of
of passing that institutional knowledge
of how to craft a bill a big idea bill
um utilizing what's available
um you know the good thing is we've got
people like Jen and Amy that we rely on
that stay here hopefully for a long
periods of time but we're not teaching
um
freshmen don't have any clue how to they
think that every idea that they have is
the first time anyone's thought of it
and they don't then are surprised when
it's been brought up 13 times in the
past so yeah
okay and that's why I was hoping yes you
notice none of our freshmen are in there
well you know they should be but it is
they were invited they were invited yeah
they were invited it's just the fact
that you know there's a lot going on I
think everybody was exhausted after the
because we've been do we've been meeting
almost every day for the last three
weeks well well every day for the last I
yeah get back because but I am going to
go forward with with the amending
language that we have here for 452 which
is relevant to the timeline and to that
possible change we have discussed today
for the for Cobra are you talking about
not the commission one but I mean
committee one but this one that we've
been looking at
yeah the one that we're looking at I'm
not going to put the committee on there
okay I'm going to put everything else on
there plus the scratch out of those four
words right does that work Amy desk I
just um wanted to also point out
something I just realized on page four
okay which one are you looking at um the
regular Amendment not the company right
here okay
um yeah the marked up one
um the amendment three two twenty three
nothing to do with the study commission
not I okay I haven't really read that
that much but on the one that you have
for the amended one yeah did this
already go through was it already a
proposed amendment okay so this is just
draft okay so on page four yeah line
five
yeah
yes but the
which I handed out
here with uh um but it also has the
committee on what it does it doesn't
include everything in the bill already
only has certain amending areas
so the just it says beginning July 1st
of 2025 because this is supposed to um
talk about the funding however
um schools submit April 1st so I think
that you need to make that beginning
April 1st of 2025. okay
they're actually
um
so schools uh the way this amendment is
should I go ahead
um the way this is set up is that
schools are applying a couple months
before the beginning of the fiscal year
um
originally I think originally that used
to say July 1st uh the April 1st was
pushed
um since that's actually the application
do you think perhaps he was talking
about a letter
no it's just that it's simply that this
legislation becomes effective in 2023
however the legislation also says
beginning July 1st of 2025 meaning our
next round of applicants which is
correct beginning July 1st of 2025 we're
going to start this process but for
those that are starting this process
they need to submit April of 2025. the
third line down that line seven
correct uh
um so but like yeah if you look at line
seven like seven it says April 1st right
that April 1st is April 1st of 2025 but
it is in a section that doesn't say it
doesn't start until afterwards right
right so either you meant to put that
applications were due July 1st which
originally was the case but I think he
moved that to a couple months earlier
well that's what I was thinking make it
before the April first
right you just can't have it be any
sooner than any other deadline so
um so would there be a problem with
saying beginning January 2025
I don't believe so
um
of the fiscal year that immediately
precedes the fiscal year
which is correct because April 1st is
the fiscal year prior to the fiscal year
that starts on July 1st April 1st is the
preceding fiscal year to the upcoming
one
split up for today
I was looking at my modifications
yeah it was good
um
yeah
yeah sure well I just had to call my
wife
okay so um there's that that's so I won
or April one January 1st
page four line five
January January 1.
yeah
it's really just an administrator it
looks like a thing
it's probably Fair ones on the
I know there's a whole slug them right
hey that's just um Technical and then
the only other um technical
um
the only other thing is that um in the
previous law and maybe this was done on
intention and that's completely fine but
um it is unclear in this revision what
school districts can apply
um in general
um the only thing I think that you're
now including that are not included
right now is potentially public
academies so if your intent is to
include public academies in building Aid
now they're not currently eligible which
um I'm sure they'd be happy to be
eligible but they're not currently
eligible because the current law
specifically defines what school
districts are this law this amendment
does not talk about what school
districts are if you leave it as is when
Pinkerton and Cole Brown ask me if
they're eligible for building Aid I will
probably I think I have to say yes which
again I don't have a preference either
way I just want to right now the answer
is no because the current loss
specifically Define school districts as
and I can send you the language
basically include
if this is written this would include
Cobra correct and if that's the intent
where where is it that that does happen
no Mission it's by uh oh mission right
now the the amendment just taught says
School District there's no definition of
school district the current building a
law defines school district is a school
district is these schools these schools
in these schools and public academies
are not included on that list so when
public academies ask me currently if
they're eligible for building Aid I say
no because the law excludes them
but this does not define that so again
um okay
and on page two we're good with uh on
line five taking charitable trust
bequests gifts Insurance yes policies
out
absolutely
yeah what we had we had yeah
from uh Colebrook and they have a
situation where the voters up there did
not approve however they have donors
that are willing to provide sizable hunk
dollar the local money local money so
that should be used
frankly the way this is written now
five
at the state ground
yeah
it's not terrible trust me again right
that's been around for years and I don't
know why it's really there because that
should that should probably come out
yeah that's what we're saying yes yes
yeah they're very sport because if I
mean if there's a generous local donor
which they have two million bucks that
shouldn't that should that valuation it
actually also solves the charter school
yes and that works for Colebrook yes so
leaving federal grants yeah yeah yes
yeah
it's been their first months
it never has well we only had what six
or seven recently Amy and when did you
think that was put into a lot of way
back yeah as far as I know I mean I've
only been with the department since late
2015 but that that is my guess is that's
just well actually I do know I'm the old
building Aid method of uh I've gone
through all of their financial
um calculations and they always take
that off the top of the project so it's
been in there for a long time
meaning when I get when we get an
application we're calculating the
well maybe they're trying to save money
from the states
well this so this is one theory is that
a lot a long time ago again I don't know
the dates on this when you were able to
receive CTE funding building Aid would
pay on the Porsche and so CTE covered 75
the remaining 25 building Aid paid 60 of
that remaining 25 and somebody said
we're not gonna have that happen anymore
and might maybe that's when that
your Amendment would but my guess is
that wasn't there and that's why people
could get funds on this their CTE
portion
gosh it's okay well we don't need to
worry about the history here let's just
oh actually according to superintendent
Taylor it was not it's not it's not yeah
that's what she said this morning
and they've she's been dealing with the
okay are you okay being the school
building authority with what's on the
bottom page four there in accordance
with criteria defined in subparagraph 2B
that is the response boys
those are the responsibilities that are
currently in law yeah you're dealing
with the the capability of the the local
to fund what they're doing
um
from that one
line 27.
the school billing Authority shall
verify the ranking submitted by the
commissioner in accordance with criteria
well I think they ought to do it in
accordance with the ranking but also
discuss as the financial means
well okay if down the road we're going
to get into Charter Public Schools oh
how do you guarantee that they're going
to have the financial ability to
maintain so is that only pertaining
well any type of I know is that your
intention and this isn't opening it to
funding jurisdiction no it's it's it's
just putting policy in place now is that
your intention that was the initial
intent nobody's here so let me say it
again is your intention that this
determining this financial needs and
to everybody school district for example
when looking at Colebrook this morning
you know she says we're tapped out what
we're 30 bucks per thousand so how am I
going to determine
that the school district or the charters
how is that how do you envision that
well I it basically that area statute
we're referencing is your responsibility
I think they put together a statement
from the District of the truck how does
the district put together
their Finance their
something that I can use for financial
we determine their financial needs that
it would be that it would be subject to
um to approval at a uh notice you know
notice
right right and so I would have to
determine whether the community has no
the community determines itself and and
it would be subject to
um to a vote at um at a
School disagreement
right well but I wouldn't
for the full disc
yeah so in terms of the timeline
if I'm approving the list
the district meeting is going to take
place
following six months later sure so so if
the district votes down the project then
then
it's not moving forward anyway you still
need something but this part takes place
six months earlier than that yeah and
they would they would have they would
they would be saying that I mean the
project is still subject to a vote at
that time right so they're basically
saying if the if the project receives
the support of the voters then the
district does have the financial
research well the tax voters but that's
so I think this language essentially
codifying it for school districts
well they did for my purposes this is
talking about me this is saying the
school building authority shall verify
ciao verified the ranking submitted to
the commissioner in accordance with this
and I have to determine the finance that
the school district has the financial
means
I don't have that information
six months prior to the meeting that
you're talking about I think I think
we're talking past each other well I
mean I think we're essentially saying
the same thing yeah well hey hang on a
second yeah so so what you're doing
right now is you're saying okay you're
uh who's your position on the list take
it to your voters uh in March and let me
know thumbs up or coming soon
you know if it's something and that's
what this is saying I I believe as far
as school districts for Charters I think
because I don't see how I am going to
determine their
uh their financial means until well
after
I've already given my rankings to the
school board
but your rankings are based upon the
criteria same criteria
that the department ranked on yes and so
you're just basically checking their
mathematics yes
and and uh yeah and what they did when
they they take this over at the the and
before and in accordance with criteria
defined so you'd be doing the checking
of the to verify the rankings and in
accordance
with you know what you're responsible
for you you do this RSA whatever to be
to be there it is
determine if that you know so I don't
know if this is necessary in here or not
this is all add-in it's not there now I
don't know how I do it unless it's six
months later and I think I've already
submitted my report
did that
by October 15th yeah wow that's what it
says right here then by November 15th
they have to approve yeah that's why
we're backing everything off here so so
how I don't
I still don't know before I stand my
paperwork to the board of ed how do I
verify that school district's financial
means
so uh just just Greg and I don't always
see eye to eye so I'm just going to
shout in here that I um I don't
understand it either
um so we're on the same page here
correct
um because then all right
um I so on the Departments and we
receive these applications and to the
extent possible we ask for their
information on their application we do
do a check on their debt ratio of their
borrowings
um and just alert them if they're above
that I think a seven percent or whatever
it is that they're allowed but I'm not
really sure what this like what happens
if he if there's something you know
we've got to submit this to the state
board for publication so I'm just not
I'm just not clear on what that would be
that's all so Amy does a does a does a
project
um make it on to the list
you know the ranking on the on the list
prior prior to receiving uh voter
approval correct yes correct okay so so
so
I mean I I think because now maybe
somebody didn't get on the list for a
project that it sorted them six months
later
say if you're taking the first four
projects the fifth project I don't know
I only give the one through seven or in
this case so 1 through 17. in in the
United States the what what what you're
saying is you're going to be on the lip
ranked on the list and then the question
is put to voters in March yeah so after
I already that's why after after you've
already reported who's on the who's on
the list
um
yeah and and sometimes the voters need
to hear that we're gonna we've been
approved for um for safe Mondays prior
to well I think voters like to like to
know how much they're going to be
getting themselves into because they
look they're either getting into 100 of
the project cost or they're getting
themselves into sixty percent and this
is the conundrum yeah
but this is the also the conundrum that
this dead this new timeline fixes
good yes it does except except we don't
I still don't this part I think I would
probably I don't know what I'm done what
I'm doing here okay here well if it's
going to be done by the department then
I I got it it's being done somewhere
I mean to the extent practical we don't
know if the warrant article is going to
pass we certainly do not give them money
until they have passed a warrant article
matter of fact with this amendment
there's some language in here that
specifically says that there Warren has
to be subject to receiving building Aid
which is different and that kind of
makes sense in this new system
contingent well it says subject to
receiving building Aid
um meaning in in well it says projects
with approval from the school district's
legislative body to construct not
subject to uh not subject to receiving
building Aid are eligible but I guess
that's not possible in the current
system because the current system you
don't know if money is going to be
appropriated but in this timeline there
like I said now they're applying now the
state budget comes out in July they're
getting ranked in November they're
getting going to their voters in March
and they can go to Construction in the
spring
so this law actually says that they have
to have their warrant written
no no not it's
well not if they want to go construction
that spring because they don't have to
wait for the state budget anymore
um can your approval be conditional
upon that funding well the article may
say that warrant article the then the
law currently says it's conditional well
well meaning it can't take funding if
making it conditional fund State funding
then you get that the vote from voters
it doesn't actually cut any taxes until
until the state funding comes in and the
project begins on true language that
could be DRL language for that I have
always my opportunities one
it means that Amy and Regina are not
doing
evaluation work on on projects that
don't have support or Community groups
which to me is you yeah this but the
town lights
by pushing back that part early
you're F you're having and especially
just take the last couple years trying
to estimate What bond rates are going to
be that far in advance
yeah yeah and the construction yeah
so that's the deviled egg slower
so I'm not sure where you gain on one
side you lose on the other and I'm not
sure
what's right so how do other states
address that wow there it's it we we
gave a lot of stuff out on the education
Commission State so doing it differently
ECS it's different what's the one that
well well I'm sure there is something
for us there but we haven't read through
that all yeah
well I guess from that standpoint you're
right
but it is I don't I don't think I know
weapon there is that you know oh this is
the winner because everyone is doing it
differently so there's not clearly not
one winner
I don't know what works here
and we've only worked really with the
one system where we're kind of
guessing what what amount is going to be
available for the next year and so we're
giving almost contingency approval
because we're ranking but we don't know
I want that brand on the timeline that's
being proposed in in
luckily too when is when is the final
approval
is there a like a final approved by the
State Board of Education that's uh
November 15th in this November 15th
well see January 15th when you have to
notify now yes but according to this
right here if you're looking on line 15
on page five
the State Board
uh education shall approved and
published a descending rank order list
of approved eligible School construction
it's also keep in mind this is not the
same January that you're talking about
or the same November it's forward yeah
we didn't move it back we moved it
forward so it's really not it's not
January it's actually that same December
and later not earlier
it's all these deadlines are later not
earlier right well it's either it's
either four months before
the the the district meeting
for its accurate
six months after eight eight months
eight months
assuming March 15th
but see that but the key is that it is
the G it is the November of the year the
state voted for the budget so it's like
if you think of it right now it's this
November so money comes in money gets
appropriated projects get ranked in in
November the list comes out so that
voters can go to their so that towns can
go to their voters already knowing what
the appropriation is for building Aid
they're going to their voters in March
of the same fiscal year of year one of
the biennium and they're actually going
to go again if they want if they need to
but in the old process here January 15th
we let them know the warrant articles
already being published yeah and and
going forward to the voters for their
scrutiny and then you can meet in March
but even worse as they're going without
knowing the state appropriation and with
no commitment from the state this allows
in one of these years to make this
prospective instead of retrospectively
like in this budget in order to make
this work in this budget would we have
to put in
yeah two one look
now this the those this doesn't start
until July 1st 2025 or the change we
just
the money would be for the projects that
we already ranked those those top three
projects Rochester Colebrook uh that
list that we just have that rank of 17
there they would be talking about
dollars of this state budget for the
this month right this month
in this is still not knowing that's what
the problem is they do not know but the
next round we're going to collect
applications we're not even going to
have a list at this time next next
budget cycle people are just going to
start to apply then the state's going to
appropriate money
um they'll know who it applies but not
not taking applications correct before
applications over two years now we'll be
taking them every year we'll be taking
them every year
um by April and so in April then the
budget comes that money is appropriated
we can tell people where they are in the
list they can go to the voters knowing
because we have money already we already
have that money and they are waiting
instead of them waiting for us we're
waiting for them to pass their warrant
article
subject to receiving building a because
they know they'll receive it because we
estimating that far in advance to appear
that's what Juan rates or what what do
you mean that first group that first
group will be two years from now like
picture two years from now we're gonna
go because that's when this would come
in effect they're gonna be applying in
April so next month they'll be applying
for construction dollars for the coming
spring that's that's good timing for
them
versus right now they're like 18 months
it'll be a year later which for a
construction project isn't that bad
right now they're almost two years out
what they have to estimate those costs
on it's just it's
right I received at that 17 the
application group of 17
they submitted their application to me
and the summer of 2020 2022 last summer
they are going to completely Miss Even
those top three projects they're going
to completely miss this construction
season because we don't know what money
they have
right now the money hasn't done money so
there if the if money becomes available
if they are
yeah
right they still don't know right they
still don't know
waiting they still estimated right even
under the present day circumstances
where the public school infrastructure
fund remember how we appropriated
dollars and even six or seven months
later the cost of doing business had
doubled right on the sudden if they
could find anybody to do the job so so
um just a just a thought you know if you
keep talking we're talking about
um uh voters that that meet either
before the the State Board decision or
voters that need captions
what if we sandwich but if it was
preliminary District vote and then a
final District vote with board decision
I'm not sure I followed that so
preliminary where where the school board
um because they're they're you know
their design team and their construction
team they put it out for bid to get a
construction quote you bring it forward
to the school district meeting in March
15th and I know that doesn't apply to
cities and stuff but but but the the
idea might apply and and you put on the
warrant
um
um uh would the voters
whatever the dra language voters make
preliminary approval from a construction
project costing no more than I think the
number 20 million dollars whatever you
get from the um from the contractor less
the school district's current building
age
um ratio is that not not contingency
so we know where our district sits
um in that
um subject to state board approval of
the building project and final
um
um approvals
yeah because these projects take six to
ten years even to get through a
School District
you know it's like any well you know
yeah generally you have multiple years
skip to bring it forward so your plan
well it depends you know behavioral one
went through and uh
couple years well I mean you could bring
it forward without you know outside of
the building a
um which is one options and get it
through in one year but if you want to
do the building age process do
preliminary and then find them with with
but if you don't do the building aid
process you might not get your building
Aid because you don't you have to have
you can't apply for building Aid after
you've started the construction project
correct no no and and districts would
still be able to make that decision on
their own yeah if they want to do it
outside would that be part of the
preliminary then if some would they vote
to do it regardless no well you
um well if they started it but they then
they no that's the middle Easter but in
the preliminary uh bar you know that
they say that they have one or two
and then if without the building agent
prove that the school board to move
forward with the project
but no build yeah day five
but we're building it any so I was
trying to think of in whether it would
be in a preliminary environment yeah
whether they
the the you know and this is this I I
like this sort of stuff because you know
there's put ideas on the table
um
he'd be here all morning
but but I think I think it addresses the
point you brought up right which is
which is and Amy that that you know
folks gets failed fast uh Bond rates
change fast so so you're always sort of
you're basically working with fresh data
at the at the time you you apply I mean
at the time you do preliminary and then
okay you think about it well I'm gonna
have my lunch here soon because we got
another one starting at one uh so I
guess I go right back down to the bottom
of that page four do we want that
language in there or not
I'm not you're not a fan either Amy
then take it out take it out and it's
not that I'm not a fan I just don't
well I think you're doing it already in
school districts
preliminary application
okay well I think Charlotte with Charter
School
that's a whole different game and uh
okay okay we're on the same page then
so that will come out because we got to
we got we gotta act on it so you're
taking out the entire thing are you
putting back in well
do this on is this on the docket for
Wednesday
yes yes so it would read the school
building authority shall verify the
rankings submitted by the commissioner
and and and make a uh a written report
of findings
it just would say and make a written
report findings and submit it list in
descending rank order to the whatever
for approval that's what you're doing
now
you're just rubber stamping
until a new process comes up and then
yeah
but if we start getting the realm of
other
organizations like Charters there's
going to have to be some real look at do
they have the ability to
Bond or or pay for it
maybe they would have all the donations
in the world so representative blood
maybe you said this but on page five on
that on the top two lines on the
strikeout I think that that that and
make a written report of findings also
needs to be struck out
which maybe you already said
because it does say it already says and
submit I think that written report oh is
that is that existing that's correct
okay I just was thinking it says and
submit a list what what written
reportify what's the difference between
a written reporter findings and
submitting the list I'm sure that if
Greg had made a written reported
findings
the financial report this financial
means part of the application process
um when you say financial means I mean
they they state where they are
anticipating their funding sources
coming from and we do a debt
um ratio check with dra you're not
allowed to spend more uh have so much
debt so so you get that information
and really it's just we use that as a
tool in case schools didn't know that I
mean hopefully they do but if they if
this would exceed their debt we'd want
you really don't need it then it just
just submit or listen just any rank
right and it's fine if it's existing
language it hasn't caused any problems I
just thought it might be hanging there
yeah I mean it's only yeah yeah I
yeah yeah
so you're gonna take out from oh yeah
that's a good point now yeah yeah that's
all out
from right after commission School
building authority shall verify the
rankings submitted by the commissioner
and make a written report of findings
and submit a list and descending rank
order
furniture
no that's not if you look that's not in
that isn't part of the funding part he
well then Okay the reason why it's the
reason why it's there is that
they can make a rank or a listing based
upon different criteria
but this right there said they got to do
it in conjunction with the same criteria
the time of this bold new language that
on page four right that says in
accordance with I think you most likely
you added that for clarification because
it also repeats itself further down
so so that's actually kind of be as
it's not part of the financial means
so
they'll say same thing done so it's just
repeated so I guess it can be sacrifice
read the sentence before that yeah yeah
it said
a little bit later on in the following
you have to but yeah it's already it's
already there
duplicative at best
yeah all the bull prank except for maybe
that and
well you could take up all the Bold at
building authority shall verify the
rankings emitted by the commissioners
and then it says right after that if the
and then representative that is super
minor
um where are you know on page six
um at the bottom it's a Roman numeral
thing line 25 I think that's supposed to
be on line 25 page six I think that's
supposed to be Roman numeral three which
I'm sure somebody would eventually
which means maybe the other Roman
numerals are
four should be three one two yes it
does this have the agent too yeah it
so then and then there's four on page
seven
no no no no see just note it and then as
you work through just yeah yeah
basically it'd be three then four and
yeah that's right
for all of us yeah
well I can look and see what OLS did do
because we
we need to really have it over there
right off here today
um
yeah we I mean and I'm gonna try to get
Jeff to do this
oh yeah how do you want to
treat this with respect to what's at hv2
and what I I believe because I did have
a conversation with her I think that she
was just sharing that information
um since
I don't recall if there's anything in
there
yeah
because that's more of the funding
structure for the other three bills that
[Music]
I'll have to look at that
school 2026.
I have had um
ETF rollover
oh maybe I'm I'm thinking of something
I can't believe they would do that right
no it doesn't it doesn't touch the you
know schedule
um but that's something I wanted to talk
about I mean obviously over time the
people who knew so many projects but but
the question is how many you know you
wanted do you want to do what same
amount every year or do you want to pick
up some more early Pro projects earlier
in the cycle given in fact we've had a
decade
well I don't I don't personally I don't
think you can look it I think that
you're seeing those projects that were
affected by by the receipts 17. when we
didn't see five right only five right
every year but
but I don't um this
this we had a slight conversation
earlier what you have um
the way of being able to take care of a
smaller projects you know take care of
five
um smaller tools and then one conquerors
can equal those five you know where
where did my ranking
but you know yeah when you're looking at
it from a
I just hearing responsibility standpoint
you're trying to say gee who am I am I
talking more people by doing five small
20 years as opposed to one year then you
can get more upfront well that's a
demonstrated dwindle as you yeah
yeah
yes and
um
in the long run more money yeah yes
well that's why we changed it to 80
percent
but we were trying to get more projects
approved
but that that works if you're sort of
all time when you're not all cut up and
you've got a backlog now you're going to
put towns making a decision to go
forward without any building because
they can't wait anymore
if you can only take so many projects or
a year
you now have a bunch of schools that are
taking a look at not submitting building
a because they're looking for ways to
handle their diminished yeah
yeah see if they can
thread the needle and and Shrink their
plant and materials before that to match
there I mean there's a lot of things I
mean talking to move forward with the
project
um uh three years ago because
um interest rates or boundaries from
solo we're like we're not gonna wait
yeah I know you know that was a good
that was a decision giving it now you're
looking to see how many applications are
that's right
well see this is all discussion we had
and this this is just cleaning up this
particular process we have
we know we're going to have to do a lot
uh
something well I think if it was a
transition plan we we put
we'd have a a 20-year payment um uh on
it and then transit to to get kind of
get out of it no no but I'm sorry but
but to get back to more of a normal uh
post moratorium
um thing where we where we only get
you know four or five applications a
year or something like that that we can
take care of but right now we've got way
too high but we don't know beyond this
curtain this transition
so what do you mean well it may be uh
funding or going there's a lot of
different scenarios roaming around the
halls right now
yeah there's some of that going on but
until all that stuff happens we gotta
clean up what we're doing well this is
what I'm saying and that's what that
um and you're going with the idea well
we'll only find X number up front and
we'll take the remaining money and
probably get a few more projects
involved
you you still you still take on that
that 38 chunk or whatever the um the the
district is qualified for but it's paid
out rather than you know 80 20 in that
first year it's paid out over that's
what we're talking about over the period
of bond yes lifetime of the bond exactly
so you just apply it to your um which is
extending the chart that Amy is
which is basically our tail yeah you
know you're extending that yeah yes
absolutely absolutely but I'm saying
that there may be a different
we may be living with that tail when we
when we're in a completely different
we still would have this fail but you
gotta recognize in the next three or
four years that tail is going to
significantly drop right
and once that drops there will be more
money available which we're doing this
well what I'm saying is that tail is
just going to take us and then we have
that level
foreign
[Music]
so we take that out
and this is just the front side you know
where you're coming from Dave right
there whether maybe we only of the
portion that's owed to that town instead
of 80 maybe it's a lesser amount that I
think is something it needs a little bit
more discussion and probably wouldn't
need to get amended into the senate or
later I think that in that so for all
policies I think we're you're putting
together a good good policy changes in
this and then maybe if we want to
consider payment schedule changes Senate
would be the place there also needs to
be a wider look at the whole process of
what that is and we've we talked about
how to do that and I think we can do it
through just a working group yeah we
don't have to have any formalized
another commission or a committee we can
just do a working group right here yeah
and and get a lot of people and people
come in with all ideas say come share
your ideas
have a bill to do that with as a
we don't we can we can set up a work
group on anything we want
and that's another way of doing it
rather it's the same thing as a
committee basically yeah just talking
about talking about ideas yeah that's
right yeah yeah um but that's the way to
do it but while we're on ideas right now
the one payment works because it's the
the payment you get from building Aid
goes right right towards the towards the
project and then you Bond the remainder
and then you get your your 20 years of
debt service on the uh on the bond the
um a 20-year payment works because the
first payment you get is is tied in with
the first year that you have the bond
payment yeah and you you know you use
that to help out with your your debt
service
five-year schedule doesn't it because
now you're going to bounce the tax rate
you're going to be you're gonna yeah
hitting well that's true yes and your
tax returns that's there right or you're
saying that's just the local issue huh
no no but but it is funny work but
numbers in between don't work well if we
go to this if we go to this smaller not
80 up front we have to recognize that
we're hurting the towns right
um
well you played well no I mean good good
value challenges too but but you're also
hurting the towns that that then have to
move forward with a building uh Project
without any
um building uh because they they were
they were ranked seven or eight there is
a downside to it even though if you
think you've been doing more projects
you're still hurting well because
because they'll be paying that's three
and a half percent on the 38 percent or
those so 60 says it would have gotten
from the plant state so what we need to
do is that we we need that substance
working group
yeah that's right so we will do that uh
but I'm Gonna Get You know some of this
going with OLS I think that makes sense
though so we can just you know get the
timeline squared away I think the
either double
or
which I gotta work I can't even
sure
almost but what we need to do we need
that time to review these projects
to keep in mind it would be great if
there was a way of nourishing one year
of the biennium
Amy and school building authority was
able to utilize that time to visit prod
visit schools
and the second year we just do this
little
pro forma here's our story
because right now we're jamming all of
those visits on both sides
October 15th and November 15th
basically the treasurer the State Fire
Marshal me
um and two other people that worked
full-time
not easy
well one always be 17 projects every
year it'll be well for a while
yeah but it will and there's a
difference between new construction and
renovation we only pick off a few at the
topic maybe 17.
Dave maybe you have two parts yeah new
construction and renovation yep he's
telling you maybe one you apply to one
program well we talked about renovation
maybe just dealing with a safety issue
yeah whereas the new construction's
dealing with all those criteria so new
renovation Renovations not going to get
any points because they don't have all
those points well maybe another
possibility too Rick would be two two
application ones
um where where where it gets paid all
a public school infrastructure to handle
Renovations and we have school building
Aid handle new project
that's another item yeah see yeah
continuing conversation but if you've
got if you've got a one payment program
and a 20 payment program representative
might be better in the 20.
yeah
put that in this thing
I've not ever thought about it did you
get that to me right now
okay
um
thank you thank you Amy
yeah chew on that one so where's this
next meeting meet I was going to ask you
well it's a senate
it's got to be across the street
somewhere
I'm going to go get my lunch in this
front seat of my car I'm not coming up
I teach a shortage
exactly
another reason
so
um
no problems
here
um
thank you
there's there's
you know like we're we're obviously a
pat Casey family for ACLS and stuff like
that but there are other good documents
too and don't don't get something done
before you need to get it done because
sometimes it means now yeah yeah you may
be good you know
whatever they put in it's never going to
be as good as the original equipment
so I think a chance to sleep in this
morning no that's
all right so
um so this is a building Aid idea and
I'm sharing it with you because I've
sent you a text but I don't know if you
get it because I don't know as if I
actually have your cell phone number and
right and that's why I actually just
wanted it was this morning
this morning yeah it was like I'll be
there at nine and I only ask because I
don't know if I actually have your
um but don't really worry about it if
not okay I'm just looking at this
morning no it's to you and
representative black so the point is
that I went over this weekend this
morning so he is aware of my just
brainstorming again
um
so the way we see it works for building
it is we find a proration amount
um of everybody
so I'm just curious if that model and